Both Spin and Exokernel started out
with the assumption that microkernel-based operating
systems structure is inherently poised for
poor performance. Why did they start with
such an assumption? Well they used a popular microkernel of the time called
Mach which was developed at CMU as an exemplar for microkernel-based operating
system structure. But Mach had portability as an important goal. If
we keep performance as the primary goal, can we achieve that with a microkernal
based approach? In this lesson, we will look at L3, a microkernal based
operating system design that provides a contrarian viewpoint to the spin and
exokernal assumption.